what's going on everybody I hope
everybody is being safe smart and
socially distant I want to today draw
your attention to the following kaggle
challenge obviously highly relevant to
today but also I find this to appear to
be much more like what the types of
tasks at least for me that I have found
businesses to need when people come to
me for like contracting and consulting
the data tends to look more like this
than your average Kaggle competition now
nothing against cago competitions
there's definitely true competition
there but generally kaggle comes down to
a competition of optimization rather
than a competition of finding insights
in highly highly unstructured data now
sometimes that's wrong but for the most
part that's kind of what you find on
kaggle because Kol has to be objective
in enforcing that objective objectivity
there's people that will optimize for
those objective results so anyways
enough on that this is a very
interesting data set I've downloaded it
and kind of peeked at it and that's kind
of why I decided no this would be really
good to do a video on I've just barely
peeked at the data and then we're gonna
dive in via code and you will see kind
of firsthand the the process that I at
least begin with looking through a data
set that this kind of data set though I
mean you will spend you know 20 to
hundreds of hours you know going through
here trying to get insights so probably
here will at best we'll see like the
first hour so don't expect anything too
crazy but this is just kind of my
process at least so to get the data just
go ahead and make an account you can
download the data also they have various
tasks here we'll talk about this in a
little bit but as you've likely found
like the problem here is there's so much
information like if we look at data it
says there's twenty nine thousand
articles and then thirteen thousand or
full-text and these are scholarly
articles just to make that clear which
is important and there's so much
information and so much new in from
it's just being pushed out very fast
there's historical information and the
new information and it's very difficult
so as you've probably found yourself
like trying to learn about this is the
variability in the information and facts
that you might hear is really high and
then not only that the variability but
there's also just there's so many like
little details that are just really
difficult and and so in this case with
the you know that there's the critical
and acute nature of what we're going
through here it's making it very hard
normally it really would be like grad
students that would sit and go through
all this stuff but we we just do not
have time for that you know and then
businesses for example like they it's
either you or they're gonna hire some
interns or something to do to try to
answer these questions but it turns out
programming can often do a better job at
it so anyway let's dig in
we'll talk about these tasks in a moment
but first start the download of data and
then we're going to start going through
the actual data once it's downloaded you
can either pause or just as your
download is going let's look at my my
file so you'll get a you know a zip
you'll unzip it and then you'll get this
basically so the last update was March
13th it is March 19th at the time of my
recording this but so hopefully at some
point maybe they'll make an update but
we'll see so coming into here this is
what we get we get these four
directories initially I kind of expected
this to be the full thing right and then
this was like the commercial subset
non-commercial subset and then some sort
of custom license subset but then I
click on here I see 803 items and then I
click on this one and I see 9,000 items
this one has almost 2,000 items and the
custom license as 1400 so that tells me
right away no we're gonna have to go
through all of these directories and
then inside the directory we have
another directory first of all just keep
this in mind with the exact same name as
the parent directory so who knows why
going on oh but then we have these JSON
files so now let's just look at a JSON
file so we know what we're looking at so
already the JSON I'm like well that's
not what I expected
they expect to be in JSON I mean maybe
it's coming from sort of jate some sort
of JSON based database I don't know
anyway so what we have here is clearly
just your your typical you know keys and
values
scrolling down okay we've the first like
body of text that we found at all is
called abstract so we can grab the
abstract okay noted then we truly have
body text and then we can already see
quite quickly it's in chunks of text so
you've got body text and then text and
then maybe some information in this case
there's really no information in their
site spans reference spans in the
section I guess I don't know so yeah
clearly we get chunks of text and then
here we definitely do have some sites
banned stuff I'm not really sure what
this is this is that like you know
character placement I've no idea no clue
but clearly we're looking for the chunks
of text inside of body text okay okay so
I think we have a general idea now
that's about as much as I want to pour
over the actual JSON files I think we're
ready to begin coding so if you haven't
fully downloaded the data yet now would
be a good time to pause so the first
thing I'm going to do is make a file so
Nano Crudup PI and we'll just say start
and go open with sublime I need to set
sublime as my default letter so right
away let's just start it will take time
to go through like each of these
directories so let's just start with
this top directory so I'm just gonna
grab the name for now later we'll go
through all for probably so we can get
all of the data possible but we're gonna
say ders equals and we'll just make this
a list whoops there we go and then
immediately what we want to do is for I
don't know D Enders
we want to let's go ahead an import of s
let's just make sure we get all the
files so the first thing we want to do
is like you know their way through all
the files so for D endures and then
basically we want to do for file in OS
dot list der and Windows F strings here
apparently because you know some people
have said that it won't like a forward
slash wouldn't work on Windows but from
my history of working on Windows for
many years I have found that even if
strings on Windows did work with a
forward slash so someone please feel
free to correct me if I'm wrong like if
you're on Windows and that's not working
and you're on like Python you know three
seven or whatever yeah I guess let me
know but it should work
hope that's not a boon to having a
problem
hopefully we're still recording looks
good we'll find out cool oh so we know
that it was the directory slash
directory so then we just want to go
through the files so the first thing I'm
gonna do is let's just go through the
print file and let's just see I also
don't have everything correctly set up
yet on this machine this is a relatively
new machine for me so I'm gonna run
everything from the terminal way just
make sure Python is so Python for me
points 23.7 Python when the file cool
look at all those okay so we are
pointing we're able to find our JSON
files very good the next order of
business is to open one so let's go
ahead and import chase and what we want
to do is I'll path will be I guess it
would just be this right here so just
copy paste slash file cool so then one
let's say J equals JSON load and we want
to load open file path with the
intention to our be cool now let's print
J and let us issue a break so we don't
get too crazy but we just
make sure things are working as expected
up to this point and it they are so so
we've got our JSON now let's do a quick
for P in J pranky let's just get a
general idea of the keys in this
document so we got paper ID metadata
abstract body text and so on so let us
know what's good for in a couple of
things so let's print J metadata we
already kind of I think I know what body
text is already gonna look like that
kind of looks pretty clear to me
metadata appears to be quite a bit of
things so you'll get the title this
apparently has no title authors oh gosh
I almost won okay let's do for K in J
metadata
it's almost would be nicer in a notebook
format didn't really plan for that okay
so really just title authors really
title that's a lot of stuff for there to
just be title and authors but okay sure
okay so what we're gonna say is title
equals J metadata title and then we also
had abstract was equal to J abstract and
then the next thing that we really want
to do is let's go forward let's print
abstract real quick I'm sure I need to
leave this up I'm gonna close these two
because that's gonna be annoying to keep
going doing that every time Oh
interesting so app abstract appears to
be in a list format which is odd
I'm not really sure what to think about
abstract being a list but would there
ever be two absent papers but having
written all zero papers in my life but
even in college I'm pretty sure there
was only one abstract but okay so
interestingly abstract zero so the
abstract needs to be abstract it's zero
I guess let's stop breaking and stop
printing and let's run through
everything to just see No okay so
sometimes we don't have an abstract so
let's try abstract except we're just
trying I'm trying to see is there ever a
time grant where it's not a list because
that does feel weird but surely like I'm
my expectation is this came from a JSON
based database so my expectation is that
everything will have the same format but
I could be totally wrong J abstract so
my thought here is that this will be an
empty list when we hit that exception
that's the only thing we're in a print
so hopefully we'll see a bunch of empty
lists yeah cool okay so except so in the
case that there isn't an abstraction
we're just going to say or abstract
we're gonna say abstract is empty just
empty string okay so all right so we've
got the abstract the title and now we
need to grab our body text so we're
going to say full text equals an empty
string for now and then for text in
where J body texts body text for text
and jaebum okay
print texts let's continue our break
because now we're going to just just try
to see like are we getting what we
expected here
for text so we needed to say text text I
guess so we call text for text MJ by
text text text me okay [ __ ] what
happened there
I said shoot by the way um okay yeah
that looks more like what we expect so
so now what we want to do is we're gonna
append this to full text so I'm just
gonna say full text plus equals text
text plus new line new line beautiful at
the very end let's print full text and
let's stop printing there and let me see
now
well we're looking at okay yeah okay so
now we finally after what has it been 13
minutes 14 minutes we've got the data in
the format that we expected to get the
data yeah but again this is more likely
to be the case of how even text data if
you're gonna get it from like for
example I've had like even retailers and
then certain news companies and trying
to think of what else I've seen
something similar to this but it is data
typically in a format that you did not
expect it's either CSV and
or JSON and not just like text documents
you might think or even crazier I've
seen quite a few things I've seen some
stuff y'all okay so okay so we've got
things organized to an extent and then I
guess the next thing I would do is
organize it into I guess it depends on
what our goal is so so we've gone this
far and now our job is to extract
something meaningful from the data so
we've kind of structured it to some
extent or at least we're close to being
able to structure it so now coming back
here in going to tasks you know I'm
looking through this list and I thought
about it a little bit initially but the
I think you know the the problem with
with extracting meaning from text as you
you want to start with the lowest
hanging fruit first and in in in this
case when we're trying to extract from
text this is so heavily an NLP or
natural language processing type of task
that in order for us to mine this data
we need to we need to know what we're
looking for right if you don't know what
you're looking for you can't find it so
the first thing is how do we find any of
these things so for example many of
these terms you know you might think
well you could just search for
pharmaceutical non pharmaceutical
intervention but many times the idea or
some you know somebody talking about a
non pharmaceutical intervention they're
gonna say it in such a way that is not
non pharmaceutical intervention there
gonna call it something else right and
they're gonna describe it in such a way
now one thing is like like vaccine the
term vaccine will probably always be
called vaccine okay another one would be
like antiviral right so antiviral is
probably always going to be called an
antiviral okay similarly looking up here
like transmission incubation and
environmental stability some of these
are you know like me personally I'm more
curious about things like you know how
is it really transmitted are we talking
are we talking three feet six feet how
long does it live on surfaces but then
even like you look at surfaces let's say
environmental stability you got
questions of like hard surfaces porous
surfaces like clothing and so on in
liquid form or liquids rather what it
gets very complicated really quick so
what we're trying to figure out is
something that does not hopefully get
too complicated too fast figure that out
and then we can start trying to tackle
some of these more ciao
so one of the other terms that I think
is highly unlikely to be changing in in
at least scholarly journals about this
is incue bation
the term incue bation like my tag and
the short keeps flipping up and it's
driving me nuts
um the term incue bation is likely to
always be called incue bation in a
scholarly journal or text or whatever in
research so my intuition or expectation
is that we can use incue bation as a
starting point because we can search
this document for incubation and
hopefully very close to where the word
incubation is used we can search for a
duration right so numbers so my
expectation again is that we could
probably do a really basic regular
expression and then later we could
really ramp up that regular expression
to find many more examples and then
hopefully filter out any mistakes but
chances are numbers around the term
incubation my guess is that these
numbers are going to be incubation times
in the form of hours or probably most
likely days so again with a lot of these
things we're looking at so many
variables like in incubation with
depending on what we're looking at we're
looking at something that could be like
minutes hours you know days weeks months
like who knows right so so you know
incubation is a general term but in this
case I think we could probably search
for digits and days and that's my
expectation so that's what I'm going to
approach with this data set first so
let's begin okay so we're gonna look for
incubation the way that we can look what
there's a couple of different things
that we could do one option we really do
have is from this point and from full
text right here in line you know I swear
I hit my tab on must hit the caps lock I
don't know anyway we could begin
searching right now even here for text
like we could just search on this loop
but not all tasks will be that easy for
us I don't think so instead what I'd
like to do is
build the dataframe so first let's just
do dots I'm gonna make that a list I'm
gonna come up here I'm gonna import
support Hannah's PD I think it was
suggested and I just ignore it and we're
gonna say here Doc's dot append and
they're going to append a list and that
will be type title title abstract I
guess it doesn't really matter the order
I suppose and then full text
okay I'm gonna comment that out also
just so we know where we are I'm going
to from tqd PGDM import tqd m and this
is just a nice way to make a progress
bar if you want if you don't have this
just pip install TQ DMS anything with
pandas pip install pandas for file in so
one thing I want to do is let's go ahead
and print D and then here we're gonna
say TQ diem around this OS dot list
d'oeuvre eventually it will have
multiple directories cool so now we'll
stop the break and let's just run that
first see where we stand and yeah we'll
go from there okay that's quite fast
well that went quick I was quicker than
I thought okay so now what we can do is
we've imported PD and prepares SPD so
now we're going to say is DF equals PE
data frame data frame title cased and we
really could just convert Docs and then
we're gonna give it the columns and this
is just a list of column names so we're
going to say literally title abstract
and then full text cool so now we have
our data frame and just to make sure
that things are working as expected
let's go ahead and output the head just
to see and things look good okay good so
now what we can actually use is the
filtration methodology that pandas gives
us so one option
it was like we can make incubation and
we can say that is equal to D F where D
F full text full text dot contains I
think this will work
incubation we will find out if that
works prints incubation head so
incubation goes D F where the D F full
text contains the string incubation
let's run a series object has no
attribute contains series object so
maybe we have to convert it to a string
so let's say 'don't spur whoa okay
this is going well uh okay so now we
have a data frame that only content
consists of body text what actually
whole articles that have somewhere in
them something about incubation we also
could have filtered by like title or
something but that went so fast I don't
I just don't think it's necessary okay
so now that we've done that I would say
we can pull out just the text at this
point later if you wanted to be able to
cite sources or something you know we
have the information necessary and just
for the record I mean at least that went
very quick now that was eight hundred
out of what thirteen thousand four
articles so things will take thirteen
times longer at some point but you know
some it just depends on the size of data
so in our case we're dealing with two
gigabytes total of data so we can we can
go pretty fast and loose with our rnd
here whereas historically one thing that
I have learned is if you are definitely
working with a very large data set
you're kind of this is what I would
describe is kind of a pre-processing
data in a pre-processing step it is wise
to save
so in this case we're just not saving
very much when I'm we're not going too
hard here because we can iterate very
quickly but normally my best suggestion
ever is it's like you're dealing with
like a terabyte of information uh in
your pre-processing steps save as much
as you can because like in the data
frame for example we can at any point we
can output this data frame so that so
like the time it takes to do like any
sort of logic and stuff you only need to
necessarily do that one time if it's a
big data set in this case it's really
not that big so we can kind of goof off
but it does I'm just some extent ok so
now what we're gonna say is we'll take
texts texting's text equals incubation
body text dot values and now we can
begin to iterate over texts so for T in
texts print T book and come over here
yeah I guess we can well just posish by
the time I figure out how exactly I want
to run it it will be too late anyways
body type Oh what is the issue full text
not what it is beautiful noises that cut
makes oh I hope it captured that
beautiful ASMR for you guys uh full text
so let's try that again and see if that
works good okay
so how are we gonna do what we think we
want to do so I um I think probably a
valid method here is gonna be to just
simply split by space I'm not space um
period so I think we can get away with
splitting everything by a period here
and then look in that exact sentence for
incubation and if we find incubation in
that sentence look for a duration which
is digits so and there will be many
problems with that hopefully I'll
remember to address them but obviously
some of these things are going to
probably do things like compare
incubation times or
it might be it might not even be a
comparison like maybe maybe in one
sentence it's it says here's the here's
one incubation time and then it's like
compare and then in the next sentence
it's like well compared to above one
it's a whole it's a completely different
even sentence so there are many kind of
gotchas that you might find in this case
that you're gonna have to eventually
probably figure out some way of
detecting when that's the case so what I
would do is I would search for related
diseases that you expect could be
compared to and then see what is that
being talked about about anywhere around
where we're about to pull an incubation
time and if it is forget about it but
for now we're gonna keep things very
simple we're gonna iterate over text and
then what we're gonna say is for
sentence in T dot split by period space
so we don't split by like decimals
alright let us print let's print print
sentence but in fact bro let's say if if
if incubation in sentence print the
sentence and actually you rather than
breaking let's print a few and just kind
of see what we're dealing with so
you don't split copy I'm a little
confused how we're seeing
how are we seeing that looks like a lot
more text than I would expect to be
seeing per split for sentence 14 texts t
was the full text right yeah
for sentence in T dot split by huh my
dog's Birkin hmm hmm why aren't we
seeing that that is odd I would not
expect to might have to pause for my
dogs going crazy
this is bad timing because what I don't
understand is okay I'm gonna go figure
out what my dogs are going on about I'll
be back okay to be honest I have no idea
I think we maybe got a package I'm not
really sure but don't know anyway
continuing along yeah we're still get
this like full text converting them to
values dot values
I believe that's what I want values um
I'm just a little confused
if incue bation in sentence print
sentence t dot split t in texts i am
slightly confused so but print text i
just i'm expecting to not see you know
we've got many example like this should
have been split why was that not split I
don't know I'm obviously missing
something unbelievably obvious here text
for team text print T that's our oh my
gosh was I always printing T are you
kidding me this isn't is that really it
is that I can't even remember now if
that was there oh that's terrible
if that's really it I'm gonna be oh dear
I guess I'll leave that in but that's
that's unfortunate
that's unfortunate hmm okay so dude
that's just embarrassing anyway okay so
we have incubation time blah blah blah
we assumed the incubation time could not
exceed 30 days okay very interesting um
48 hours so like we're gonna find stuff
like that I don't know that's not very
good
the average incubation period was seven
days okay so that's an example of
something we're looking for estimated
the incubation 5.2 days ok so that's
another example that we would look for
the this article selects the incubation
period as seven days
okay so you get the idea I think we can
look for
just to start up and look for examples
of digit some digit space days right we
can do that very simply so and then if
we find I would also say we will only
accept examples where we find incubation
and then one digit space days example
and then the sentence has to be done so
for example and the reason why I want to
do that is like here so we say ok the
incubation period is seven days blah
blah they keep talking yak yak in latent
persons seven days ago now this could be
this could be anything right it doesn't
necessarily like this could be some
other number of days I think this is
still in reference to why it's seven
days but I you might have scenarios
where you have these like two variations
so if there's more than if we've you
know if our logic is hey this is how
we're gonna find incubation times and
then we find two digits now in some
cases it could be a digit
you know incubation time of seven to ten
days or 7-10 days we might find
scenarios like that but we might also
find scenarios like this where it's not
they aren't related to each other so if
we find that scenario and we find more
than two instances then our logic is not
solid and we're just going to toss it so
so let's just start with something super
basic because that's what we need if I
can't even figure out how to split text
and not lose it okay if incubation in
sentence print sentence cool we're gonna
use a regular expression so let's say
import or don't worry I'm no regular
expression expert as I'm sure you will
soon see let's say single day and we're
gonna say that is equal to a readout
find all and its pattern and then the
thing so we are going to look for some
sort of regular expression in the
sentence so so the first single day
expression that we are gonna hunt for is
going to be some
that is really wanted to so like one you
know
either single digits or double digits
followed by a space followed by at least
da why because sometimes that'll be ours
and stuff such so we definitely need to
be looking very specifically for day so
single day redefined all blah blah okay
so if if Len single day equals one then
we're assuming this is a good find
so let's go ahead and rope let's go
ahead and print a single day zero and
let's print the sentence and then we'll
tab over these just for a nice beautiful
formatting and then no that's fine we
will see a few examples
what is going on okay so it's a two day
seven day I'll come over printing this
sentence here why do I keep getting
bitten by for getting old prints I
really don't appreciate ah beautiful
eighty nine day no they said jet where's
the 89th even coming oh my gosh should
we say but okay here's a question why
did it find point eight nine oh because
then it was followed by check okay so
what we're gonna say spa take that let's
try that one
were you at 89 days gotcha
as soon as this 21 is 21 susceptible
compartment return okay
oh the matte so they do think 21s is the
maximum incubation we've got 14 day at
least 14 days and we stress that 17 to
14 10 days here so possible okay okay
okay cool so okay that's a good find as
you can see we did see various things
like 2 to 14 days also how come you
didn't find the 2 and then throw this
away I don't really know 14 day oh
because it was 14 day copy that
okay mm-hmm like I said regular
expression expert uh so so as you can
see already like we would probably want
to search this and this and then also
search for 2 to 14 days to - 14 so many
things that we'd want to search for
we'll keep it nice and simple for now
however so if we find a single day what
do we want to do from there the other
thing I bet we're missing is like you
know these these are keeping it two
whole numbers like seven but chances are
a lot of articles have decimals as well
I don't think I could try my hand at a
possible decimal let's let's try it
hey let's do it let's show the people
how terrible of a programmer I can be at
times so let's say we wanted to have a
possible decimal that means you would
have a slash day a digit rather thought
you know one two - one two - followed by
a period and this whole thing we would
have zero or one occurrence of and then
another digit right
let's see what happens let's see five
dots okay so that's problem five oh why
didn't it find five got to rule isn't
that can tie in case that I thought I
could get me I thought I could encase it
with parentheses is it brackets maybe I
wish I could remember uh cuz we really
want all that together otherwise we
would get up to four digits and we don't
want four digits we want that is it
maybe the parentheses what I screwed up
maybe he is it a bracket yeah you're
already congratulations you already seen
how terrible I can be at times no I
don't think a bracket is what we want
someone comment below remind me the
basics of regular expressions because I
want this whole thing possibly but for
now let's keep it simple like I said
yeah you got to see how terrible I can
be because we want those two things
possibly and I just don't know there's
got to be some way to I thought it was
with parentheses but I think I'm wrong
anyway as we saw because you'll get like
that leading number but not the
following number and I think that's
because the parentheses like picks that
part to find like I think the
parentheses means you're gonna find
you'll find what's in the parentheses
and this stuff still has to be found but
you'll only find like it's only gonna
return what's in the parentheses when
instead yeah I want that group
I just don't know I'm not not good
enough my apologies
someone comment one below and we'll get
it somebody will do it okay so we have
single day great so now what we want to
do is let's say incue bation
times will make that a list and then we
will append let's see how far we are in
time here another ten minutes I think I
stopped at 25 because of my lovely
animals incubation times so what we're
gonna do is if we do find it I think I
was pretty happy with what you know this
regular expression did for us
so just wanna make sure I didn't screw
up when I removed our other
it looks good we will just add them to
this list so what we'll say is incue
bation times dot append and while these
are int but later we might find floats
given somebody who knows how to write
regular expressions but are there moi
will say float single day zero so again
these should all be actual integers at
this stage but I think eventually you'd
want to have the possibility for a float
the other thing we could use like if I
was doing this for a client you know and
I really wanted to know the answer to
that question and I could not figure out
how to write a freaking regular
expression I would legit just single day
int single day float that's the kind of
programmer I am but for now we'll just
do it this way and cool we don't need to
print out anymore that's kind of
pointless very good very good at the
very end let's print let's put both
incubation times am just curious what is
the Len of our land of our incubation
times beautiful save rerun this where
where did we forget a
really show me again line 62 oh okay we
never closed off that parenthesis I see
again could not of course append float
let's split by space we'll just say numb
equals a single day zero so we're
basically we're trying to just grab the
number from and I actually think you
could split by day I think you can
convert space isn't a number two just a
number I think you get away with that
but we could split by space let's just
do not split by space print num break
so in every instance it is the first if
element as I was hoping but I just want
to make sure so num one fantastic just
clean this up a little bit
okay so already we have 71 examples of
incubation times and it looks like our
largest is like 42 maybe yeah
looks like that's the biggest one so
then what we could do is slowly begin to
possibly wrap this one up import let's
see import mat plot map port map lot
lived up hi plot as PLT and then let's
go ahead and have style from Matt plot
live we're going to import some style we
going use some style and we will come
down and we will say PLT dot hist and
remind me yeah okay so the the array and
then the bins so it will be incubation
times and then we'll do bins ten PLT dot
show the y axes PLT dot why was it label
yeah beautiful we're gonna say counts I
guess bin counts
PLT dot X label will be incubation time
days beautiful beautiful
we are coming down the homestretch there
we go we got a nice histogram of
projected incubation time again we
probably caught some things that we
should not have caught here so we still
have a lot of work to do but I think
I'll show one more thing and that is
well a couple things one do we have
just quickly import numpy as NP and can
we get away with French the mean
objected incubation time what is it NP
mean incubation ups queue Batian times
let's run that okay about ten days will
add days to that as well so yeah that is
the projected kind of average okay so
possibly extracted some meaning there
days okay
finally we only went through that one
set of files so let us add the others
and hopefully with her all organized the
same way we're gonna find out calm you
subset mm-hmm let's grab the
non-commercial use subset and finally we
will ground but the custom license
copy-pasta save let's try again
hopefully that doesn't take forever it
looks like it very well might take
forever how come those first eight
hundred go so fast and then this one go
so slow well the good news is I'm
already editing this so maybe I'll just
kind of speed it up and make a cut
because I already have to edit this
because of my lovely animals
um while we wait on that let me think if
there's anything else I really need to
talk about I'll edit this whole thing
out if if there isn't um yeah yeah I
guess one thing I would do is maybe come
check out some of these kernels to be
honest um like I don't know what a lot
of these things are so understanding
paper with text analytics like there's
probably a lot of really great ideas
here's even a rule set incubation period
let's see what they've done it looks
like they've gone a little harder on on
making their matches let's see what they
found what did you find
interval mat room yeah so that it looks
like he built like something really
specific term match our interval match
her period manager interesting
interesting what you find looks like
this is an incubation period um oh well
here's ours how much data was that let's
go look real quick so we got 562 with
the mean projected incubation time of
nine point one one and what was this ten
bins I think it was ten bins
one thing we definitely should have done
is saved this array because it takes so
long to create that array or list rather
whoops cuz how many bins did you go with
bro what did he do PLT - oh he just made
a bar graph he has lots of bins anyway
okay so um yeah so we can see you know
on average somewhere between zero in ten
days is like the most but then if you
were to like stack up all these bars
here you know get to like 18 or whatever
this number would be it would be pretty
high so some of it up to like 20 days
looks to be not a shocking number now of
course I would the next one of the next
things I would do is try to figure out
what's going on here why is there
something there also let's uh even
though we didn't save it as an object we
can cheat like I wonder if we give it
more bins I do want to kind of see a few
more bin
so what I'm gonna do come on down here
and I'm going to say incue bation x
equals pasta I'm proud of myself for
just copying it let's change this to 30
bins save one more attempt okay so we
make more bins okay so we can clearly
see like these I might even so like if
as I look further and try to fix this
program I would look for each of these
and see what what did we get that gave
us these because I don't think those are
real incubation times so we'd want to
you know figure out where those came
from to determine you know how can we
better improve our script but yeah it
looks like somewhere between five and
five in I don't knows what is that seven
five and six days probably five and
seven where's the mouse a seven
looks like the incubation time is
probably five to seven days on expected
average but then you know like I said
looking before if we took this one
stacked this on top here stack this over
time here it clearly you know more than
ten maybe even up to two weeks yeah so
anyway okay so some starting information
I'm sure we made lots of you know
incorrect polls we are missing a lot of
data because I'm sure many days we're
using decimals and I just I'm just not
smart enough to make sure their
expressions apparently I honestly just
have not done regular expressions and it
might even be years now like I just
haven't had to deal with them I usually
get Daniel to write them so anyway yeah
so so interesting initial insights we
could keep going with this and keep
trying to find more examples and stuff
I'm sure there's much more incubation
stuff in there that we could pull from
but then using kind of a similar
methodology we could start to be curious
about some of the other tasks that are
on here maybe you've got an idea of
something you want to look for or maybe
you want to do something totally
separate from what I've done here but on
the data set anyway it's a cool data set
and it's obviously an important data set
and I think it's a realistic data set I
mean it's as real as
this is a real problem that we're
actually experiencing right now and I
mean just just the data set in general
this is a data mining problem so anyway
I think that's all if you've got
questions comments suggestions concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
if you've got something cool you can
feel free to link it below I'll check it
out also usually on on kaggle like I
said like I would look through some of
the kernels maybe participate some of
the discussions and stuff and probably
learn some really interesting things so
yeah that's all for now
I hope you guys are staying safe and I
will see you guys in another video